Mit einem starken Infrarot-Laser Kontakt zu
außerirdischen Lebensformen aufnehmen!
Diese Idee kommt vom renommierten Massachusetts
Institute of Technology (MIT) in Cambridge.
Demnach könnten wir mit unseren technischen
Möglichkeiten schon in wenigen Jahren solch
einen Laser bauen, dessen Leuchtsignal man
noch in einer Entfernung von 20.000 Lichtjahren
entdecken könnte.
Das Forschungsteam schreibt, dass sich damit
sogar eine Botschaft in einer Art Morsecode
senden ließe.
Wie stark müsste solch ein Laser sein und
wie genau könnte die Kommunikation mit außerirdischen
Leben ablaufen?
Clixoom Science & Fiction Hier gibt es täglich
faszinierende Sciencevideos - Abonniert den
Kanal, nur dann verpasst ihr nichts. herzlich
willkommen!
Dass da draußen im Weltall weiteres Leben
existiert - davon sind viele Forschungsteams
felsenfest überzeugt.
Doch wie können wir es aufspüren?
Wie können wir mit möglichen Außerirdischen
Kontakt aufnehmen?
Und könnten sie uns vielleicht sogar den
Weg zu lebensfreundlichen Planeten ebnen?!
Ein Team vom MIT hat jetzt einen neuen Vorschlag
gemacht, wie wir Menschen Außerirdische auf
uns aufmerksam machen könnten.
Und zwar mit Hilfe eines künstlichen Leuchtsignals.
Konkret könnte dies mit einem Infrarotlaser
möglich sein.
Ein sehr starker Laser mit einer Leistung
von zwei Megawatt wäre dafür notwendig und
zudem auch ein mindestens 30 bis 45 Meter
großes Teleskop.
Dies würde dafür sorgen, dass der Infrarotlaser
scharf gebündelt ins All leuchten könnte.
Beides wäre nach Ansicht des Forschungsteams
technologisch gesehen schon jetzt bzw in sehr
naher Zukunft möglich.Dazu einer der Studienautoren,
James Clark: “Es wäre ein herausforderndes
Projekt, aber kein unmögliches".
Im besten Fall könnte das Signal dann noch
in einer Entfernung von bis zu 20.000 Lichtjahren
nachzuweisen sein.
Da sind ganze 80 Prozent der Strecke bis zum
Zentrum der Milchstraße.
Die größte Herausforderung sei es bei dem
Projekt, die Sonne zu überstrahlen.
Und dies ist natürlich nur mit einem unheimlich
starken Laser umzusetzen.
Den MIT-Wissenschaftlerinnen und Wissenschaftler
schwebt deswegen ein Laser vor, der etwa eine
Milliarde Mal stärker ist als gewöhnliche
Laserpointer - wow!
Dem Plan zufolge müsste dieser im besten
Fall auf einem Berg gebaut werden, denn somit
könnte verhindert werden, dass das Signal
auf seinem Weg in der Atmosphäre verzerrt
wird.
Doch klar ist auch: Objekte im Erdorbit wie
Satelliten wären durch solch einen starken
Laser-Strahl gefährdet!
Das Forschungsteam hatte deswegen auch schon
die Idee, die Rückseite des Mondes als Standort
für dieses Projekt auszuwählen.
Und es geht noch weiter.
Denn mit dem Laser könnten wir Menschen ja
nicht nur durch das starke Leuchtsignal auf
uns aufmerksam machen, sondern sogar kommunizieren.
Dem MIT-Team zufolge wären Botschaften aus
einigen Dutzend Zeichen möglich, die pro
Sekunde Lichtjahre weit in All getragen werden
könnten.
Dazu Clark: “Wenn wir eine Verbindung mit
Nachbarn einrichten könnten, könnten wir
eine Botschaft morsen (...), die in einigen
Jahren dort ankommen könnte.”
Klar ist aber auch: Je weiter die andere,
bisher noch unbekannte Zivilisation, entfernt
ist, umso langwieriger würde die Kommunikation
natürlich werden.
Ganze acht Jahre beispielsweise müssten wir
uns auf der Erde gedulden, bis eine Antwort
eintreffen würde, die direkt vom nächsten
Nachbarstern der Sonne namens Proxima Centauri
an uns gerichtet würde.
Proxima Centauri ist vier Lichtjahre entfernt.
Unglaublich lange 1000 Jahre würde es dagegen
dauern, bis uns eine Antwort einer außerirdischen
Zivilisation erreichen würde, die in einer
Entfernung von 500 Lichtjahren existiert.
Doch bereits laufende bzw. umgesetzte Projekte
zeigen, dass die Idee technisch gesehen tatsächlich
gar nicht so unrealistisch ist.
Beispielsweise hatte die amerikanische Luftwaffe
schon einmal einen Megawatt-Laser an den Start
gebracht.
Der sollte ursprünglich dafür dienen, den
Luftraum zu schützen und Raketen vom Himmel
zu schießen.
Aber keine Sorge: Er ist mittlerweile stillgelegt.
Und auch der Bau eines derart großen Teleskops
liegt durchaus im Machbaren.
Das zeigt das Beispiel der Europäischen Südsternwarte
(ESO), die in Chile derzeit in Teleskop baut.
Der geplante Durchmesser beträgt 39 Meter.
Dazu Clark: “Grundsätzlich war das eine
Machbarkeitsstudie.
Ob es eine gute Idee ist oder nicht, ist Diskussionsstoff
für künftige Arbeiten."
Stephen Hawking jedenfalls hatte dazu eine
ganz klare Meinung.
Er riet von einer Kontaktaufnahme mit Aliens
ab.
Seiner Meinung nach könnte dies dazu führen,
dass sie überhaupt auf uns aufmerksam werden
und uns dann zerstören!
Außerirdische Mega Zivilisationen finden
- So könnte es gehen.
Draufklicken, anschauen und Neugierzone abonnieren.
Bis dann, bleibt dran!